Thank you to Shortform for sponsoring this
video.
To get a free trial and an additional 25%
discount on the annual subscription which
includes unlimited access to their browser
extension, join Shortform at shortform.com/microcosmos
or click the link in the description.
I’m going to cut right to the chase.
We’re looking at the inside of a potato
right now.
Yes, seriously.
When you take a little slide of that bland,
mushy flesh and put it under the microscope
with polarized light, this is what you see.
I can’t speak for you, but this, is not
what I expected.
Potatoes are a great food, but they’re not
exactly the most exciting to look at.
I certainly never expected to see something
that could double as the stained glass windows
in a Sailor Moon fever dream.
But that varied array of colors is built out
of something simple: starch granules.
Those granules act as storage for the plant’s
carbohydrate supply, which is then stashed
in the potato tubers underground.
The starches are meant to provide energy for
the potato plant.
But of course, plenty of animals (including
us) like to make use of the potato’s sparkly
starches as well.
And when you look inside other foods, like
passion fruit and bananas, you can see those
starches as well, sometimes packed into cells
or at other times, flowing across the slide.
Perhaps, if you’ve been journeying with
us through the microcosmos for a while now,
you may have noticed that these images look
very different from our usual sights.
Of course, that’s partially because we’re
looking at very different things from our
typical fare.
Usually we’re looking into pond water or
whatever other fascinating bit of nature that
James, our master of microscopes, usually
looks at.
But right now, our sights are coming to us
directly from the kitchen.
But also, things are looking a bit different
because today, we’re looking through the
lens of a different master of microscopes.
Her name is Chloe Savard, and you can follow
on instagram at tardibabe.
Chloe got her start in microscopy three years
ago, after seeing some videos on instagram
that piqued her interest.
She started slowly at first, but it’s since
built into a huge passion, helping her see
the world through that combination of
artistry and science that microscopy
inherently blends together.
These videos of the crystals inside of dragon
fruits are some of our favorites of hers.
It looks like she accidentally dropped a giant
container of neon confetti onto her microscope.
But those funky shapes are probably a type
of sugar called myo-inositol, which crystallized
as water slowly evaporated from the slide.
If you watch more of what Chloe sees through
her microscope, you’ll see spectacular colors
over and over again as she renders different
crystals in vivid terms.
And she’s able to do this using a type of
light called polarized light, which restricts
the electrical field vibrations of the light
to one plane.
To our eyes, polarized light looks the same
as non-polarized light.
But under a microscope, we can see the effect
of polarized light hitting certain types of materials—
in this case, the crystals in our food—
as it forms a dazzling tableau.
This effect has been part of the excitement
of microscopy for Chloe, especially because
she loves the saturated colors she’s learned
to bring out with her microscope.
That’s how she’s able to see the stone
cells inside of fruits like pears and blueberries.
These cells aren’t alive, but they still
serve a purpose:
to support the fruit, and sometimes even to
protect them from threats like weevils.
Their walls are full of sturdy lignin, which
is responsible for the gritty texture you
feel when you bite into a pear.
Even though these aren’t like the microbial
life we usually watch under the microscope,
there’s a similar feeling to them, like
we’re unlocking this tiny world that’s
responsible for everything we experience.
It’s just that instead of, say, a tiny algae
responsible for the air we breathe or a parasite
that can eat away at a body, we’re experiencing
an invisible universe responsible for the
way that our foods feel and
taste and sustain us.
Like have you ever eaten a pineapple and immediately
scrunched your face up in pain?
Well, that might be due to these structures called
raphides made from calcium oxalate crystals.
A number of other fruits and plants have raphides,
and there are a few theories about what raphides
actually do.
Given that they look a lot like needles,
one idea is that they might function
as protection, prickling away at the mouth
of anyone who dares eat the plant.
But crystals aren’t the only surreal sight
buried in the microscopic worlds of fruits
and vegetables.
If you look at the inside of an onion or a
pumpkin, you can see a streaming motion within
the cells called cytoplasmic streaming, or
cyclosis, though we have the movement
sped up a bit here.
This motion is a cell at work, using a network
of actin and myosin to carry organelles and
other molecules around so they can carry out
various tasks in distant regions.
We’ve been looking at a lot of fruits and
vegetables, but that’s not all Chloe looks at.
If you go to her Instagram, you’ll see videos
of some of our favorite microcosmos friends,
like tardigrades and diatoms and worms.
Like James, she has an office full of stinky
jars that are full of samples taken from ponds.
But there has been one major challenge to
her love of searching for microscopic life
in ponds:
winter.
In Montreal, the cold temperatures often keep
her from finding new samples for months.
That’s why Chloe started looking at fruits
and vegetables.
It was meant to help her bide the time.
But after she looked at the inside of a potato,
she was hooked.
She’d never expected starch to be so beautiful,
or to find similar structures in different
types of molecules.
But there they were, an array of striking
colors apparent under the microscope.
Compared to pond samples, which can rely on
hours and hours of patience to sort through,
fruits and vegetables offered something immediate,
which meant she could experiment with the
artistic side of microscopy in a different
way as well, learning to bring out those structures
and colors.
There is both an art and a science to turning
the fruit bowl into a subject in this way,
crafting a still life that reveals itself
to not be so still after all.
With every beam of light, Chloe takes us on
a tour of something we see every day, and
helps us see it through her eyes:
as something surreal and beautiful and mind-blowing
that is just within our reach.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Shortform for sponsoring
this video.
Feeling overwhelmed by the never-ending sea
of new books?
Don't worry, you're not alone.
With tens of thousands of new books hitting
the shelves every week, it's impossible to
read them all.
But fear not!
Shortform is here to save the day with their
incredible book guides that offer comprehensive
summaries, commentary, and analysis—
and deliver key insights in just minutes.
How many times have you heard someone suggest
that you read Dale Carnegie’s book “How
To Win Friends And Influence People”?
Heck, maybe you even have a copy collecting
dust on your bookshelf right now that you
just haven’t made time for.
Well, thankfully for you, Shortform can get
you up to speed with their “How To Win Friends
and Influence People” book guide that contains
a 1-Page Summary, a full chapter-by-chapter
guide, and even Interactive exercises that
prompt you to reflect on the ideas you’ve learned.
And Shortform knows you're always on the move.
That's why their book guides come with audio
versions, allowing you to listen and learn
anytime, anywhere.
Shortform drops new book guides and articles
every week, and as a subscriber, you have
the power to shape their content by voting
on the books you want them to cover next.
And their latest innovation is the Shortform
AI Browser Extension.
Now you can experience instant summaries wherever
your web browsing takes you.
Blogs, articles, emails, YouTube videos—
you name it.
Their AI extension generates concise summaries,
effortlessly delivering key ideas right to
your fingertips.
To get a free trial and an additional 25%
discount on the annual subscription which
includes unlimited access to the extension,
join Shortform through shortform.com/microcosmos
or click the link in the description.
We also want to say thank you to all of those
people whose names you’re seeing on the
screen right now.
Those are some of our Patreon patrons and we
couldn’t continue to make this show without them.
If you'd like to see more from Journey To The
Microcosmos, there should be a subscribe button
somewhere nearby.